hello and welcome to the video for
selfie school coordinators
in this short video the selfie team will
give you some tips on how best to use
selfie in
your school through selfie students
teachers and school leaders
reflect on and answer a series of
questions
on how to use technology for teaching
and learning
your school gets immediate feedback and
the results can be used
to identify strengths and weaknesses and
plan for improvement
there are three types of question in
selfie a set of questions that are the
same for every school
a set of optional questions that you can
choose from and because every school is
different
you can add up to 10 of your own
question to suit your needs
download the complete list of fixed and
optional questions to get a detailed
overview
this will help you see if you want to
add anything for your school
selfie can be run up to three times
during the school year
once in any of these three periods
you can give participants from one to
three weeks to answer selfie questions
choose dates that suit your school
calendar so more staff and students can
take part
once the first selfie question is
submitted these dates can no longer be
changed
participation in self is anonymous so
participants can freely express their
views
as no personal information is stored it
is not possible to save the answers
and return to complete it later students
and staff have
up to two hours to reply to selfie
questions
it takes around 20 minutes for students
and 40 minutes for staff
to complete safely selfie is available
in more than 30 languages
staff and students can answer the
questions in the language they prefer
we recommend that the students answer
the selfie questions
with the teacher during a class that way
the teacher can explain what selfie is
and why the students are being asked
their views if your school
offers more than one level of education
you can choose where you want to run the
tool
for example just primary or
both primary and secondary also you can
choose to run it for each level
at different times selfie questions can
be answered on any device
such as smartphones tablets or pcs as
self is an online tool you need a stable
connection when answering
if the connection is unstable students
and staff may have to restart the
questions
the more people taking part in selfie at
your school the more accurate the
results will be
check out the guidelines in selfie
platform for the optimal participation
rate for your school
once staff and students have reply to
the questions
a report for your school is
automatically generated
this interactive report highlights
what's working well
and where improvement is needed you can
display
and compare data in many useful ways
focus on high scores
low scores and see how students
staff and school leaders agree or differ
on the views on technology use this
should help you gain understanding of
where action
is needed once you have completed selfie
you should discuss the results within
your school community and agree on
follow-up actions
since selfie can be run on a regular
basis your school can compare results
assess progress over time and adapt its
course of action
staff and students can download a
personalized selfie certificate
as soon as they have completed the
questions once the user session is
closed
it is not possible to download or
request the certificate as
not data on participant is stored also
your school can receive an open batch
for taking part in selfie this
recognizes your school commitment
to using digital technologies to support
teaching
and learning feel free to share your
experience with selfie on social media
to help us spread the word
we hope you found this video helpful if
you have questions or suggestions
please get in touch the selfie team is
here to help
you